-Our next guest is
a Grammy-nominated
comedian and actor.
He'll be appearing live
at Radio City Music Hall
September 23rd to the 25th
as part of his "Fun Tour."
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Jim Gaffigan.
♪♪
[ Applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
Oh, my God.
-You look nice.
-Wow, you guys!
-Yeah, this is really nice.
-Thank you so much.
Thank you.
-Oh, don't milk it.
-Thank you.
Thanks so much. Thank you.
-They get tired
if they have to keep clapping.
-Thank you. Thank you.
No, I am not going to
make you -- Thanks so much.
-Welcome.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Well, this will be --
Radio City won't be a big deal
after you came out to this.
-Well, it's going to be weird
going back to Radio City.
Because, as you know, I was
a Rockette for a while.
-You were?
-Yeah.
-I don't think I did know that.
-I was fired --
You know, I was part of
the Christmas spectacular.
I don't know if you brought
your kids there.
And I was fired.
They caught me in a situation
with one of the donkeys.
Nothing --
-Okay.
-Nothing was going on.
-Okay, gotcha.
-I mean, the donkey was
definitely flirting with me.
-Right.
-But --
-But that's a fireable offense
as a Rockette.
-Essentially, I got
a donkey pregnant.
[ Laughter ]
But it's -- you know,
it's, like, fine.
-Wait. Nothing happened?
-My wife doesn't know.
-Oh, okay.
-So don't bring it up to her.
She'd freak out.
-She doesn't watch the show.
-She'd freak out.
-[ Laughs ]
So you played MSG as well.
Those are kind of the big rooms
in the city.
It must be thrilling.
-You know, I'm so excited.
And, you know, when I did
Madison Square Garden --
'cause my kids are going to come
and see me at Radio City.
And I was like,
"Well, you remember
when I was
at Madison Square Garden."
And they were like, "No."
And it wasn't even
that long ago.
It's like kids remember nothing
'cause they don't care.
-Yeah.
-They don't care.
Because children are just God's
punishment for having sex.
[ Laughter ]
I know that sounds hard.
-You guys have had a lot of sex,
'cause you have a lot of kids.
-Five times we've had sex.
-[ Laughs ]
You have five kids.
-Five kids.
-Last time we talked
was April of 2020.
How did you hold up?
How did you make it through?
-You know, the pandemic --
I actually --
Well, I died in June,
which was weird.
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
-We can cut that out.
[ Laughter ]
-You did look a little --
-I mean, I looked a little pale.
-You've lost some color. Yeah.
-I mean, it was crazy.
You know, this is going to
sound pandering,
but I feel as though the
pandemic was hardest on mothers.
-Mm-hmm.
-Definitely mothers, right?
Or the men who had to
live with those mothers.
[ Laughter ]
But it was insane for everyone.
There was, at one point, I --
I turned to my wife --
I guess it was after I finished
the first case of scotch.
And I turned to her.
[ Laughter ]
And I said,
"When this is all over,
I will take you wherever
you want to go.
Wherever you want to go."
And my wife was like,
"I want to go to Hawaii."
And I was like, "Well, I was
thinking more tri-state area."
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
-Sure.
-She was like,
"I want to go to Hawaii,
and I want to bring the kids."
And I was like, "Whose kids?"
[ Laughter ]
And she was like, "Our kids."
And so I did research,
and it was cheaper than
a divorce, so we went to Hawaii.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
-And what an amazing place.
Right? It's like no other state.
It's just --
It's a tropical paradise.
It's almost like Hawaii was
this Polynesian island nation
that we just took over.
Do you know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
Like, it wasn't even part
of the United States.
We just went in kind of like
it was, you know, an open house.
We just looked around like,
"Oh, this is nice.
We can have our wedding here."
You know what I mean?
And the Hawaiians were like,
"We're our own country."
And we're like,
"You're coming with us."
[ Laughter ]
And if you've been there,
you know that --
you know, understandably,
there are people that are angry.
-Yes. Justifiably so, yes.
-They'll come up to you
and they'll say,
"You stole this land."
And I'm like, "I don't know
how to break it to you,
but we stole all the land."
[ Laughter ]
You know?
It probably just stings
a little more
'cause this land is prettier,
but there's even people
in Detroit mad at us.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
-Now, I would imagine --
I don't like the beach.
I would imagine you don't.
-No, no, no. I do not.
I know I look like I --
I just spent --
'Cause my wife loves the beach.
And so I just spent the entire
vacation just applying
and reapplying sunscreen, which
thankfully makes my skin whiter.
-Right.
-You know.
I don't know what cruel bastard
decided that the goo
that protects pale people
from the sun
should also make them look like
white walkers.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Do you know what I mean?
I just didn't want to be the --
I didn't want to get burned.
You don't want to be
the sunburned adult.
'Cause, you know, we've all --
You know, you see a kid
with a sunburn, and you're like,
"Parenting's hard."
But you see an adult
that's sunburnt
and you're like,
"That's an alcoholic."
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
-Right?
You need to avoid that person.
Like, sunburned adults always
look a little lost, right?
'Cause they're looking
for the bar.
[ Laughter ]
-That's why they look lost.
Did you do activities?
What activities did you do
when you were there?
-You know, I don't know why
all the vacation activities
require a waiver,
you know what I mean?
-They do now.
-On vacations. Right?
-I feel like that's a new thing.
Yeah.
-Yeah. It's like,
"Sign here. Have fun.
Hopefully you don't die." Right?
-Yeah.
-And we did zip lining
for the last time.
That's just --
-Did you not like it?
-What is wrong with humans?
It's like, "Oh, do you want to
feel like you're about to die?
Would you pay $200 to feel like
you're about to die six times?"
It's like why don't you just,
you know --
Why don't you just go to a biker
rally and take off your mask?
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
Why don't you walk into traffic?
I don't know.
But sometimes when my family
would go to the beach,
I would go for a hike,
which is boring.
But I figured out
how to make it fun.
Whenever I go on a hike,
I always bring a ketchup packet,
and halfway through the hike,
I open it up and I rub it
on my hands and my face,
and then I just approach
romantic couples and ask,
you know,
"Have you seen my wife?"
[ Laughter ]
And they're like, "Uh, no."
And I'm like, "But you heard her
sassing off to me."
[ Laughter ]
It's like,
"I can still smell her scent."
[ Laughter ]
That's inappropriate.
-That's a good transition
to the fact that your show
is called "The Fun Tour."
-It is fun.
-We deserve fun.
-We do deserve fun right now.
I feel like -- I don't know --
I feel like people are happy
to get back out and do comedy.
But I know a lot of people,
justifiably so as well,
wearing masks.
What's it like to do comedy
to the masked?
-Well, it's great
to have another barrier
from hearing laughter.
-Yes.
-Right? But no.
It is -- There is -- I mean,
I did the drive-in shows,
which were horrible.
-This is people, like,
honking for laughs?
-Yeah. That's when you're
trying to, like, you know,
someone flashes their lights.
You're essentially trying to
make the person
that is the most sober
in the car laugh,
because they control things.
-Yeah.
It's interesting, so you're --
I'm assuming you were
trying new material and your
feedback is lights and horns.
Could you process "this is
working, this isn't working"?
-Kind of.
Sometimes people would tailgate,
but it was just very weird.
-Yeah.
-But, by the way, at Radio City,
they have --
you know, everyone has to be
vaxxed so people don't --
If you're vaccinated,
you know --
If you're under 12,
you have to wear a mask.
So, there are -- It's -- And
there is an energy, as we know.
It's like people
want to be entertained.
-Yes.
-People are sick of
their families.
-Very sick.
-And so they need a break.
-And yet, they -- I think they
enjoy listening to someone
like you tell jokes about how
you're sick of your family.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
I think we all need,
you know, some therapy.
Right?
-That's a very universal thing
that you are very good
at sharing.
-Oh, thanks.
-It's always a delight
to see you.
Have great shows over there.
-Thanks so much for having me.
-For more information on tour
dates, go to jimgaffigan.com.